wired autocomplete interview yes should
we try to say it again
okay I'm Cobie Smulders and I'm Billy
Eichner and we're doing the wired
autocomplete interview doesn't roll off
the tongue you get exhausted talking
about yourself I don't like talking
about myself no okay you ready okay what
is Cobie Smulders Cobie Smulders real
name jacoba Francisca Maria smolders
whoa
my father is Dutch and so that's why I
have two middle names my great aunt was
a lovely woman by the name of yo Koba
went by Kobe Wow and I was named after
her are you first-generation
Canadian yeah after Canadians I don't
want to hear about that how did Cobie
Smulders
get famous what does it mean to be
famous I could ask me this she said
aren't you famous and I said what does
it mean to be famous and she goes people
like what you do and they're excited
about you well I mean I don't want to
throw your child under the bus it's
really yes but at least you're famous so
she doesn't have to be smart right if
we're gonna really answer the questions
go there getting on How I Met Your
Mother
yeah it was the big thing today yeah the
big break was that is Cobie Smulders
anything in Avengers yes Wow I was in
the first Avengers and I was in the
second Avengers we'll just have to see
if there's more avenging to do what are
they avenging at this at the are
avenging a lot cuz right you know there
was the the only half of us died I don't
watch those movies what happened to
Cobie Smulders and Avengers ID I turn to
dust I turn to dust that was the last
that we saw that's the last thing we
know well we'll see what happens see
what happens
dust I can come back I can come back any
time watch The Avengers find out what
was Kobe small errors in friends
she wishes I do she wouldn't be in the
friends from college if I had friends
money yes No did you watch friends was
that a big show for you um no oh this is
yours yeah okay
how tall is Milly actor Billy Eichner is
6-3 but shrinking when did you have your
growth spurt I was always the tallest
kid oh really
way so I didn't really have a spurt but
that sounds disgusting I was always the
tallest kid yeah which is lovely but
awful if you're tall and still terrible
at basketball but I can dance who'd play
in Lion King very exciting very exciting
I play the voice of Timon the meerkat
who sings Hakuna Matata
didn't do the Little Mermaid okay next
did Billy Eichner win an Emmy no let me
tell you I've been nominated okay for
two Primetime Emmys and one Daytime Emmy
which is all to be nominated for a
Daytime Emmys already horrifying it's
not prime cases for Billy on the street
yes okay they nominated me for best game
show host which is only a category at
the Daytime Emmys okay right and I lost
to the host of Cash Cab hello we're not
doing the same thing no that is not the
Soliman he's a lovely guy but imagine
losing to the host of Cash Cab and then
I lost two Primetime Emmys next Billy
Eichner hosts Oscars not will Billy
Eichner need pro now I think you would
do an amazing job I think that you would
flesh it you would do such an amazing
job I don't think I'm there yet yeah
professionally culturally I think you
would do great thank you did you did you
feel like Vanna White when you were like
I feel very thought like Vanna White and
I have to say I've never felt more like
myself Ken Billy
Captain America wouldn't you be better
you bet I can
captain all over his America I think
that might have to do with a popular
meme that's right someone took a clip of
Billy on the street where I'm running
around with a group of wild lesbians and
I'm saying let's go lesbians let's go
someone took that audio the way people
do on the Internet and they put it in
the mouth of Captain America from in a
scene from Captain America so he was
shouting let's go lesbians let's go that
became like a yeah beam of sight yes I
do remember that that was very funny
yeah let's go lesbians let's go lesbians
let's go is Cobie Smulders married yes
to Taran Killam next question yeah is
Cobie Smulders in agents of shield I was
in the pilot of agents of shield and
then I was sprinkled and maybe you one
or two other episodes fantastic is Cobie
Smulders Canadian my way
that's my québécois exam oh my way yeah
are you a dual citizenship no we have a
green card but trying to get that well I
haven't applied for it yet but I hope no
way to try yeah yeah it's Cobie Smulders
left-handed I'm right-handed I'm
left-handed
he's Cobie Smulders engaged to Josh
Radnor no I guess I was on the show
maybe people think that we dated but we
never dated oh you're married happily
married and Who I am
is Billy on the street real yes it is
real those interactions are not scripted
they're not cast unlike some other shows
I know which I will mention Cash Cab
Cash cast in advance yeah that's more
like it is Billy on the street
in American Horror Story yes what's your
last name
I am Billy on the street and I'm in
American Horror Story I'm not doing the
Billy on the street
persona in American Horror Story your
acting your play-acting actors over here
Laurence Olivier that's what I do next
like like someone watching the wired
YouTube channel knows who Laurence
Olivier is is Billy on the street
the honey badger guy someone took a
nature video from my like a nature
documentary on honey badger and some
flamboyant performer added a voiceover
to him that was like honey badger don't
like or whatever it was something like
that I went very viral and people
thought it was me I guess it kind of
sounds like a Billy on the street type
of thing right it is not me and I'm
sorry to disappoint
who is Elena on bill Elena is a real
woman I ran into on Billy on the street
one of the only real person on celebrity
that I ran into who I brought back to
the show a bunch of times because she is
unbelievably funny go on YouTube right
now she will destroy him
are you ready no I'm excited how did
Cobie Smulders meet Aaron let me tell
you guys it's a really sweet story the
first time I met Taryn he actually does
not remember meeting me oh he was
shooting a pilot and one of my good
friends was in it as well and I went up
to him after the pilot and I said hi
Paul's friend just wanted to say great
job does not remember meeting his muse
really not know the first time we both
remember meeting each other it was at a
roller rink in Northridge whoa we were
22 years old Wow
so young and you started dating then and
yeah it's still going like met had a
date maybe two days later together whoa
dude how old Cobie Smulders how old
Cobie Smulders rude I'm 36 I'm happy to
be 36
okay I'm 31 so she's older who cares
it's not a big deal okay
coby's small are Cobie Smulders Alison
yes I love Alison we are friends she's a
lovely human being do you guys keep in
touch a lot the How I Met Your Mother
cast we you know that's a no okay
next can Cobie Smulders sing sing
Oh like like Oh Billy Eichner what
happened that is a good question there
was so much potential
now it's squandered on YouTube I should
be in movies you are now now it's a
cartoon let's get real whatever whatever
okay how much is Billy Eichner worth
eight million dollars
how old is Billy Eichner not sexist you
get to say how old you are too if you
want to I am 40 40 40 and 40 years you
just turned 40 this year like in
September timbre did you a big thing I
did a party fun yeah it was alright can
Billy Eichner sing I yeah I was a
musical theater student in college I
sing in friends from college in a weird
way my god we just talked about that
which you had to hear literally 40 times
every time was so amazing watch her show
Billy sings during his wedding yeah I
think of in you by Minnie Riperton well
I don't just get them all of us that's
it that's a little tease does Cobie
Smulders yes speak now Dutch no no I
know wants to hear about now who does
Cobie Smulders look like Liv Tyler I've
got oh yeah that's it there you go
yeah well you really ran the gamut yeah
does Cobie Smulders have a baby hey if I
mean I did yeah
and now they're older than a baby but I
did have children yes how well do that
they're nine and four well that's cute
yeah they're very sweet
does Cobie Smulders have a sister I have
my sister Melissa my sister Amy my
sister Fiona only sister Julie
who is do we think we know what it is
Billy Eichner you google it
you're already online you just Google
this that's what you wrote in idiot good
use of your time
is Billy Eichner nice I lovely she had
to work with me so that's true but you
know what it's worth it I leave it all
on screen he puts it all out there and
then you don't ever want to see him
again
exactly I like there right now he's
lovely
thank you it's Billy Eichner single oh I
am single so maybe stop googling and
ladies start googling you know where to
find me
Grindr is Billy Eichner on Bob's Burgers
I am I do a boy some burgers I love that
show
I enjoy doing a great cast money ain't
bad you know that's it that's not that's
all right I'm so glad we did this
I'm so glad we finally answered your
questions yeah yeah did you guys like
this did you enjoy why it as much as we
enjoyed though are you watching it to
begin with
I was Kobe I've been Billy and this is
was the wired autocomplete interview
thanks for your time thank you for
watching us